إذا تحدثت إلى أشخاص مصابين بالشلل،
فإن أولويتهم الأولى هي أنهم يريدون
استعادة وظيفة اليد والذراع حتى
أعلى من ذلك، فهم يعطون الأولوية لذلك فوق
القدرة على الوقوف والمشي مرة أخرى، وإليك
كيفية عمل الغرسة التي يتم وضعها على
الدماغ فوق القشرة الحركية للذكاء الاصطناعي في  تقوم
أجهزة فك التشفير المزروعة بتحريك أصابع اليد والذراع
ثم تنقل هذه
المعلومات لاسلكيًا إلى
عملية زرع أخرى في الجسم، وبالتالي تجاوز العمود الفقري
التالف، الذكاء الاصطناعي في تلك الغرسة
يحفز العضلات الصحيحة للقيام بالفعل
بتلك الحركات التي يسمونها
الحركة المدفوعة بالفكر، أجرت الدكتورة جوسلين بلوك
الجراحة  نزيل
القليل من العظام ونستبدل هذه القطعة من
العظام بهذه المجموعة من الأقطاب الكهربائية ثم
نغلق الجلد، وستعمل هذه الزرعة
لاسلكيًا وتنشط
تحفيز الحبل الشوكي، وكان شريكها،
عالم الأعصاب، قد خطرت له فكرة الخيال العلمي هذه لأول مرة منذ
سنوات مضت  ثم انتظرت حتى تتمكن التكنولوجيا من
اللحاق بالركب، إذا كنت مشلولًا في
يدك ويمكنك فقط الفتح والإغلاق، فهذا
تغيير حقيقي فجأة يمكنك أن تأكل،
فأنت تكتسب الاستقلال، فإن التغيير
في نشاط الحياة اليومية
مثير للغاية، هذا هو هذا المشروع الجديد
من المثير جدًا أن التقينا بلوك وجريجوار
كورتين في يوليو لمناقشة مشروعهما السابق،
عالم آخر أولًا يلائم
جهازًا مشابهًا لهذا الرجل الذي فقد القدرة على
استخدام ساقيه بعد حادث دراجة،
والآن أصبحت الغرسات قادرة على التقاط
أفكاري حول المشي
و  قادرون على النقل إلى
المحفز الموجود في أسفل ظهري لكنهم
يقولون إن استعادة وظيفة الذراع واليد هي
في الواقع أصعب، إنها أكثر دقة
خاصة إذا أردنا توسيع نطاق
استعادة الحركة لتشمل الأصابع
وليس فقط الذراعين، لذا ساعدهم على فهم
شيء ما  أو مساعدتهم على استخدام
الأرقام الفردية بينما لا يزال الوقت مبكرًا جدًا
لتقديم النتائج الكاملة، أخبرنا أنه
يسعدنا أن نعلن أن
التكنولوجيا تعمل كما هو متوقع ويبدو أنها
نجحت في إعادة تنشيط
ذراعيه وأصابعه المشلولة، وسنتعلم الكثير
من ذلك أولاً  شخصًا، ثم سنتوسع
إلى أربعة أو خمسة أشخاص، وبعد ذلك إذا سارت الأمور على
ما يرام، فسنجري تجربة محورية عالمية
ونأمل أن نحصل على موافقة إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
ونجعلها متاحة، ولا يزال هناك الكثير من العمل الذي يتعين
القيام به بالتأكيد، لكنهم مع هذه
العمليات الجراحية التجريبية  لقد أثبت أنه يمكن
القيام بشيء اعتقد الكثير من الناس أنه
مستحيل، استعادة الحركة بعد
إصابة في النخاع الشوكي، أخبرني أحد القانونيين في أفسس أن
الكثير من الناس يمكن أن يستفيدوا
من هذا، لدينا
واجب أخلاقي لمواصلة هذا البحث، لقد
بحثنا في هذا وأكثر من ذلك بكثير من أجل
سيتم بث حلقة من القصة بأكملها هنا
على قناة سي إن إن الأجنبية الشهر المقبل